[Music]
very pretty picture from thailand
president putin's invasion of ukraine
has led to suffering for his own people
including russians who were overseas at
the time and now they're trying to get
home international sanctions have left
many with no money at all and with so
many flights to russia canceled they
have no easy way to return before their
money runs out elizabeth palmer met up
with some of the thousands of russians
who were stranded in the popular tourist
destination of phuket in thailand
thailand's tropical beaches and
turquoise seas
don't look so much like paradise when
you're running out of money with no way
home
max casillo is one of thousands of
russians trapped here by fallout from
the invasion of ukraine
his bank guards stopped working when u.s
led sanctions kicked in and visa and
mastercard cut off russian accounts
then he and his partner artum siddharth
found out that their flight like most to
russia had been canceled how worried are
you
kind of worried because this situation
we don't know what's going on we don't
we just
don't feel safe i scared to be in russia
and i scared to be here the resort
island of phuket has catered to russian
tourists for years but the war has
turned what should have been a vacation
into a nightmare i'm worried for the
future
i don't i don't know
i have haven't figured out how we'll
leave
just don't know
juliana maligna got money from an atm
just before they stopped working so she
can still feed her girls in their rented
house
but not everyone is so lucky i hear lots
of stories most of them said some
russians
don't have
cash their cards are blocked
and they even don't have money to to buy
food stranded russians have set up an
online help group with advice on flights
and cheap rooms and not only for
themselves
people here help
both russians and ukrainians it doesn't
matter of the nationality russians help
ukrainians and
ukrainians help russians resort owner
toka terkelson is offering desperate
russians free beds
and they tell him things they won't or
can't for their own safety say to our
camera they're actually telling me that
they should get rid of putin of course
and what are they telling you about the
war are most of them against it all of
them against it they're ashamed and for
our children max there's a discouraging
message from family back home my mother
says don't came to russia mine's the
same they
feel not safe for me to be in russia
right now hard words to hear from loved
ones
but for as long as they can afford it
they've decided to stay put
the real urgency for thousands of
stranded russians now is to get access
to their money somehow so they can
either buy a ticket home
or simply survive abroad while they wait
out the war for cbs mornings i'm
elizabeth palmer in phuket
wow a reminder there's a difference
between everyday russians and then the
russian government and the russian
military distinct groups